my dear brothers and sisters someone
sent me a video of uh you know brother
I'm going to I respect from Uncle
because I don't know this person by the
way I never seen him I never heard of
him uh he's old Uncle from palistine
um claiming that I called Palestinians
mush mus
subh this is big slunder Allah firstly
we start with making Dua to Allah to
protect our brothers and sisters in
Philistine likewise around the world
those who have been oppressed and give
them Victory and I never
called how they say I'm I don't make I
don't make people then you come and you
say
I so clearly he didn't watch the whole
video we were speaking about um was a
long conversation with some Arabs
talking about what's happening to Muslim
countries around the world sometimes bad
things happen to us because is a test
sometimes because why due to our sins I
mentioned that so not everything that's
happening to us because we are we're
doing sh or doing Haram we're doing
something because everyone's doing sh
and uh him himself admitted there is
there is people that worship graves in
in Philistine and you claim to be the
student
of I will highly recommend you to listen
albani said about the issue of
philistine and uh so why I will ask you
bring your
proof bring proof that I said
Palestinians are because if I say there
is a shik in Palestine that doesn't mean
are everyone is mush in Palestine there
is a shik in Algeria that doesn't mean
every Al is a mush no one would say Shi
is saying the algerians are mush I
mentioned many times there's a sh in
Alger Morocco no one came out and
claimed that shi is saying all the AL
are mus but now because Philistine
what's happening is emotional thing
people have people have desires and
misguidance are utilizing it to make me
look back and now what I said I said
look I'm with my brothers and sister
intine by the way it's happened it's not
the best movement and what happened look
now Subhan Allah who are suffering our
brothers and sister in Gaza may Allah
protect them and may Allah give them
Victory and may Allah destroy the zist
for kill our brothers and sisters in
festine because they are the biggest
terrorist who are killing people without
any mercy and we have this uh uh Western
uh me uh uh mainstream media the biggest
monic on the Hypocrites they're not
speaking out and even they try like pce
Morgan I'm going to digress bit peace
Moran this biggest MF he was so hard for
him to just condemn this evil act just
be a normal human being what's happening
to our brothers and sisters is
oppression but again bring you proof
when I said Palestinians are that is a
big lie and may Allah guide
you